rules requiring voters to show ID for
the first time in England come into
Force for May's local elections
it's up and down the country there are
huge numbers of people without one up to
3.5 million many of them unaware that
they could be turned away next time they
try to vote
disproportionately affected our people
are no incomes and in rented
accommodation those on unemployment and
disability benefits and the elderly
people aged over 85. it's just another
obstacles for people from
underprivileged backgrounds or for
marginalized communities to birth the
government say a similar system has been
used in Northern Ireland since 2003 and
the changes are needed to stop electoral
fraud despite just one case across all
UK elections last year